I enjoy being a woman in science,
different fields,
what my field is one where I'm often
working with mostly men,
um,
but,
but there are more and more women coming
into science and I think that there's a
lot of issues around it.
I'm actually involve them in the
National Academy of Sciences Committee
for Women in science and engineering and
medicine and we spent a lot of time
thinking about what were the issues.
Um,
and I think that there's very important
transition points that we need to focus
on.
So a lot of women will do sciences,
undergraduates,
but then fall out going to graduate
school and then there's a bigger follow
that happens to postdoc.
So why is it,
is there this attrition?
So,
you know,
really focusing on nurturing women
through their transitions.
Obviously there's a lot of cultural and
biological differences with women and it
makes it difficult because science is a
very challenging job and you do have to
make sacrifices and think about how can
you do it in a way that will work for
you.
So,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I haven't,
I've enjoyed it and I think that in
general,
um,
people try really hard,
they're just cultural differences that
you have to understand and there's
things I have to reckon with personally
of how to do my science and be assertive
but still be,
you know,
kind and assertive and all sorts of
things and how to balance work and life
and all of that.
So,
um,
it's challenging and I think that
there's a lot that can be done.
I mean,
we definitely can.
I talk about in America that I feel like
I can't speak for the rest of the world.
I feel like in America there's lots of
opportunity for women in science.
It's not about the opportunity,
it's about motivating women to enter
science and a lot of the k through 12
education of getting them engaged
earlier on,
but then also supporting them,
you know,
supporting them through the transitions
because no matter what we say there,
so fundamental differences with trying
to,
you know,
with the things that you have to contend
with being a woman.
Um,
and so the opportunity is there,
it's just the support systems need to do
better.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
it's a lot of people say,
and there's a couple of things,
a lot of people say,
um,
you know,
uh,
like asked me how it is that I do,
you know,
I have an md and a phd and do research
and also have an outside life and I'm,
but you,
no matter what,
there's 24 hours in a day.
So I don't like to pretend like,
oh,
it's just so easy.
Like you make sacrifices and,
you know,
um,
I wasn't being that healthy for awhile.
I've regrouped and been like,
okay,
now I have to focus and you have to
focus on the longterm.
So going to the gym,
doing the yoga and all sorts of things
that you have to do in order to sustain
yourself for your students and for
everyone.
So,
um,
there are challenges at every stage and
it's easier to do when you really like
what you do.
So that's,
that's the important thing,
right?
Is the idea of liking it.
Even when you're failing,
it's failing in it and when it's hard
and just just liking it in general,
like you get a lot more energy and
everyone knows that you have these sort
of flexes of high energy and low energy
and if you can maintain yourself in a
place where you're always very focused
and energetic and excited,
then you can do a lot more.
Um,
and a lot of that comes with finding the
thing that's your passion.
So once you find your passion,
the day to day gets a lot easier.
So I love music and I would just do it
anyway.
Um,
so whether I was in a band or not,
like I write music all the time,
so it's easy.
It's not actually challenged in a lot of
times I'm embarrassed to say like write
songs,
like on my bike ride to work.
That's the kind of thing that I do
naturally and,
and engage in.
So it gives me time if I was to do
something that was totally,
you know,
write a book that's out of my field and
obviously that's a bigger sacrifice.
Unless it was something where the ideas
are just being for me and I was just
really engaged in the process,
so there is definitely challenges at
every stage of being active and keeping
it and sacrifices I've made.
Like I,
I've,
I'm,
I haven't started a family yet.
I'd like to,
but obviously the,
the,
when,
and if I do,
that's going to be another thing to
bring into the mix,
which is challenging.